[inaudible]
joining me today is an Iraq war veteran,
a political analysts at America's favorite Black Gay Republican.
Rob Smith.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
Thanks for having me there.
America's favorite Black Gay Republican.
That's a lot of pressure to put in a Twitter bio.
You know,
it's a lot of pressure.
I feel that,
um,
about a year ago about this time,
because I came out as conservative a year ago and I,
I out as conservative,
fascinating phrase that we're going to talk a little,
get into that.
Absolutely.
But when I came out I said I want something pithy and catchy and kind of funny
because it's a joke,
you know,
America's favorite Black Gay Republican.
I want there to be a sense of humor in it because as you know,
you know,
you use humor to bring people in,
then you hit them with the facts.
So a lot of people are going to be going,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
These guys are supposed to hate identity politics.
But he's saying he's America's favorite Black Gay Republican.
Well,
here's my thing with that.
I think that there's a,
number one,
all politics is identity politics.
So everybody does identity politics.
The left does it in the right,
does it,
I think that since coming out as a conservative,
the way I play identity politics is this,
I'm black,
I'm gay,
I'm going to rock war veteran,
I'm all these different things and they don't matter about my politics because I
can be all of these things and still love America.
And the way the left plays identity politics is we hate you,
evil white men or you know,
this is my 72 genders or all this stuff.
So I feel like they use identity politics not only in a super negative and
controlling way,
but as a way to get people's votes.
80 sucks though,
to kind of have to do a little bit of what they do to throw it in their face.
Right.
Cause like any time,
I don't mention that I'm gay that often,
but anytime that I do,
I have no problem mentioning it.
Like I'm more than happy to talk about it.
Yeah.
But anytime that I do,
it really only is to throw the use the way that they use gay people.
Uh,
it's to throw that back in their face like I have no,
I don't want special credit for it.
You know?
I mean there's,
there's no special credit.
I think that for me,
when you get into my history and you know,
I'm going to rock war veteran,
I protested against,
don't ask,
don't tell.
And I came out at 19 or I came out at 19 kind of like to myself in a couple of
friends of my mother.
But when I got out of the military at around 21 years old,
because I had to serve under,
don't ask,
don't tell,
I said I'm done with closets,
so I'm going to be out as gay.
So being gay to me has always kinda been a political act.
And when I was protesting against,
don't ask,
don't tell,
and getting arrested at the White House and doing all these different things,
it was always a political act for me to be gay.
So even coming out as a conservative and being on the right,
and I'm proudly on the right,
being gay is a political act because I have to go into these spaces and say I'm
gay and this is why that matters and this is how we can change the party and
change the idea of conservatism to bring more people in.
Do you ever find that conservatives have problems?
We gave people because people keep telling me that all these conservatives hate
gay people,
and I go to events all
over the place,
all over the country,
all over the world,
and I meet all these conservatives.
I'm not saying there are none.
I have no doubt there's a certain sect of Bible thumpers obviously that's still
do or some people that have different religious beliefs.
You know,
Ben Shapiro from an Orthodox Jewish perspective,
not thrilled with gay marriage,
but now takes the libertarian approach civil than which I'm okay with.
I don't need him to bow to my beliefs,
but I don't find that there's any real push back against gay people from
conservatives anymore.
I just don't see it.
This is what I've seen
and I've seen very,
very little in the way of people having some problem with me being gay.
The um,
in my experience,
and I've been,
God,
I spoke at the Metropolitan Republican Club in New York City and I,
and I speak at these republican events all over the country and it's not so much
I have a problem with you being gay.
It's some people say,
um,
one,
one person came up to me and she said,
you know,
you're so good looking and you're black and you know,
you're all these things.
Like why do you have to talk about the gay thing?
And I told her,
I was like,
I talk about the gay thing because it's very important for me to talk about it
because people need to know there are gay conservatives out there that follow me
right now that are afraid to come out.
And so I need to take this gain as to the space and let them know that it's
okay.
And also let you guys know that you're missing out on a base of millions of
voters by,
by doing things that can even be construed as it.
Yeah.
You think it's one of those things where it's sort of,
you have to do it so that it can get to the point that you don't have to do it.
Is that really?
Yes.
Yeah,
and I was having this conversation with,
with Candace and I shared this at the blocks are rally over the weekend as well.
Um,
doing identity politics,
you do it now so that at a certain point we don't have to do it anymore.
So we have to say that I'm a gay republican or I'm a black republican or I'm a
gay,
black,
conservative,
whatever you want to say.
Because as Americans,
we have to break all that stuff down and figure out what our identity as
Americans is.
And that's the point for me.
Yeah.
All right.
So I want to talk about what it's like coming out as a conservative,
as a gay black man.
The rest of it.
But let,
let's just back up.
Yeah.
All together.
Tell me a little bit about growing up in a family,
that kind of thing.
Yeah,
so
I am from Akron,
Ohio.
One of the biggest,
um,
things that people like to say to discredit black conservatives is that we were
all born wealthy.
We were all born them upper middle class.
And what we're doing is we're just trying to protect our privilege.
I'm from Akron,
Ohio.
You weren't in Bel Air.
I was not in Bel Air.
All right.
I was in Akron,
Ohio in check the stats on Akron,
Ohio.
Anybody that doesn't know where that is,
um,
went to the worst one of the worst public school systems in the state.
You can look on the website right now.
I can,
public schools are rated d plus.
So I came from a single mother household.
You know,
I came from all this stuff and my mother tells me this story and I was too young
to remember,
but obviously I went to kindergarten in a school that was in my neighborhood and
my mother tells me the story about going to see me in kindergarten one day.
And it was just,
you know,
90% black school,
let's just to the people were just running around crazy and she said,
I had to pull you out of that school because I knew you weren't going to learn
anything.
Wow.
Send me to school all the way across town.
Um,
the school was,
was mostly why that doesn't make it better or made it better was the property
taxes and it was just a,
a more funded school.
So I was able to get that kind of base,
went back to my side of town for middle school and high school,
which was just a terrible experience.
I,
and I tell people all the time when they asked me about,
you know,
sort of things in the world,
in Western civilization,
all that,
I'm like,
look,
I went to Akron public schools.
There are so many things that I just do not know.
Um,
and so I had that experience.
But in those days,
and probably still today,
somebody that looks like me,
that comes from where I'd come from if I'm not dribbling a basketball or doing
whatever they like,
they don't know what to do with you.
So it's not tracked in the college.
I wasn't attracted to any of these things.
I graduated high school at barely,
I think it was either 16 or barely 17 and just had no path.
So I joined the military right out of high school because I needed a path.
I needed a job.
I needed something to do.
I wish that I could say in,
in my military service is great and I love this country.
And that five years that I spent in the military is probably the greatest thing
I'll ever do.
But I can't lie and say that as 17 years old,
like I was so patriotic,
I wanted to serve my country.
It was a way for me to move beyond.
Yeah.
All right,
well before we get to that,
I can't let anyone mention basketball.
I got,
I got a boy.
You got any skills now?
I don't.
I'm the word black man.
Ever.
I like am terrible at basketball.
I don't want to Brag,
but I won most improved player of the New York City gay men's basketball this
year.
I think 2012 when I was already like 37 which could be most improved player at
37 that's not bad.
That's pretty good.
It's really funny that I'm,
they have that gay basketball league there.
There's a part of me that has always wanted to try,
but I know it'd be so bad and there were guys dunking.
I mean it's a serious,
it's a seriously you got,
it's funny because I don't mind,
I always,
for me at least,
and I wonder for you,
like my sports and my sexuality had nothing to do with each other ever.
Like I never brought my sexuality when I'm out on the court in any way.
You know what I mean?
Like it wasn't like that.
The only reason I joined that league was at that point in my life when I came
out late and I finally was like,
Oh,
let me just meet some,
I didn't really like like the bar scene or like yeah,
like I didn't,
I didn't like that and I was like,
Oh man,
if there's happened to be some gay people that also like basketball maybe you
know,
I'll find some friends and I did find some friends there and it's like,
and half of them it's like you're gay.
Really?
Like the guy like dunks on you and like some of those guys,
like almost when pro,
that's how good they've got.
The weird thing about kind of like being gay and not only am I gay,
I was so used to be a fat kid as well,
so I think you're really going for it here.
I'm like,
God,
everything.
Did you have a limp at any point?
Did not have a line like five.
Like I said,
I was like some fat black gay kids was not athletic at all.
So I
didn't discover because there are some sports I'm good at.
I played in in the Gay Volleyball League in New York City for a couple of years
and now I'm a pariah since I came out as conservatives.
Oh,
GPA.
I thought they're all talented.
Yeah,
right.
New York City gays,
they're not tolerant.
This is not so much,
I am shocked,
but I discovered that I am athletic and I discovered that I'm great at
volleyball,
great at tennis,
you know,
like,
like lifting weights,
like being in shape.
But that's kind of what I discovered about myself.
Kind of like,
I don't want to say later in life,
but definitely post 30 that I actually,
you know,
have some sports skills.
Yeah.
All right,
good.
So when you joined the military,
we,
you,
were you already sort of out to yourself?
Now I'm talking about sexuality,
politics,
not politics,
NYSE,
but certainly not a conservative thing.
I was,
I was out to myself,
I think in the way that a lot of gay teens are.
You know,
I knew that I was kind of like feeling away about guys that I was supposed to
feel about girls,
but I don't know if I could really kind of quantify it in that way.
Um,
and when I went into the military,
they actually,
in those days I actually asked you,
are you gay?
And I said,
no,
I'm not,
only because I didn't know how to define it at the time,
but also I knew that that was a barrier to,
to what I wanted to do,
you know.
So being in the military,
I came out to myself,
you know,
started exploring my sexuality,
exploring all of that stuff.
And like I said,
when I got done with the military,
coming out was like a political act.
I was like,
no more closets.
Were you finding other gay people in the military?
Like what is that?
What was that like then?
I mean,
now,
now where it's more accepted and donate until doesn't exist or whatever.
The thing about,
um,
it's really funny how it is now is that there are entire Instagram accounts
dedicated to gay guys in the military.
It's called gay military dudes.
And I,
and I love the fact that these bees,
young gay men in the military,
so open about their sexuality and their posting thought picks and they're doing
all this.
And I'm like,
great.
You were saying the military hasn't crumbled since and it's causing a
demoralization or everyone's still okay.
We still,
everybody still good.
But back then there was this,
this underground movement of,
of gay people,
gays and lesbians that were in the military.
And I remember the very first pride I went to,
I was,
um,
I was stationed in Fort Carson,
Colorado,
so like right on Colorado Springs.
And my very first pride was Denver pride.
So I went there and I think it was like maybe 19 or 20 at the time.
And that was my first time being around a lots of other gay men at the same
time.
And it was the first time that,
um,
you know,
I was,
I was getting attention from men and then like,
people were looking at me and I was like,
oh,
he's cute.
And I was like,
oh,
so this is what this is like.
Um,
so there was a thriving underground gay culture in the military.
How do,
were you afraid to go out and go to a gay pride parade while you're [inaudible]?
Absolutely.
Because it's like if I don't ask,
don't tell was tricky because it was not only,
you can't tell somebody that you're gay,
but if you were discovered to be gay,
then people would,
um,
you know,
go up the chain of command and kick you out.
But the thing about it is,
and this is what we always realize,
that nobody would care because there are plenty of guys in my unit that,
that knew I was gay and a funny story,
there was a club called,
I think it's now defunct,
called hide and seek in Colorado Springs and they used to be open to people
under 21 after 2:00 AM.
So I would be,
yeah,
yeah.
It will be opened at 21.
Uh,
it would be open to people under 21 after 2:00 AM because it'd be like open till
five and they wouldn't be serving any booze.
So I was young in the military.
I was like maybe 20 years old,
I would take a nap at 10 30 at night.
I wake up at one 30 I would put on,
I had like,
like leather pants and a tank top is insane.
Crazy.
Um,
and then drive to hide and seek and dance all night.
And it was kind of,
it was a more gay crowd,
but it was mixed as well.
And I saw a couple of my sergeants there,
wow.
Time at the club and they saw me,
they saw me and they saw me and they were like,
okay,
this is interesting.
And they saw me kind of like dancing with some red head and you know,
feeling my oats,
you know what I mean?
Feeling myself.
But I remember being terrified that weekend that they were going to out me,
that they were going to like tell my superiors and whatever.
It never did
well,
but you had it on them too,
right?
I mean,
no,
they weren't gay.
They were,
they were just there with their girlfriends because it was like,
oh wow.
I just had a completely different story going on in my head for the last 30
seconds.
Yeah,
no,
they were there with their girlfriends.
Oh,
they're our spot.
whoa.
Yeah.
Gotcha.
Okay.
And so they did.
They did
bust me out in a lot of these guys are still my friends to this day,
my Facebook friends,
and they see all the stuff that I'm doing.
I'm here on there and coming out as a Republican.
I'm doing all this.
And they're like,
Smith,
you know,
we always knew you were gay.
We just didn't care because you're a good soldier.
So I know what most gay people feel about being in the closet.
Just how you can be as a person.
It's just,
you know,
you're,
I always felt like I was like lying all the time accidentally.
Like I was,
it wasn't even intentionalized people would ask me something and I could
immediately,
you know,
where were you last night?
And I could just lie without thinking,
you know,
it's really,
it's a really twisted,
dark.
It's not fun to think back on that kind of thing.
Um,
but for someone in the military during don't ask,
don't tell,
do you think that affected your ability to function as a,
as a soldier and I think it did
the,
I think that to me the biggest thing about being closeted in the military was
that it affected the relationships that I was able to have with my fellow
soldiers.
There was a wall there and if I was able to just be gay and nobody cared,
that wall wouldn't be there.
And,
and it's so important when you're serving with people to be able to be close to
them.
Like literally to be able to,
to bring your full self self to work.
Because not only were we serving together,
I mean we deployed together,
you know,
I did a tour in Kuwait,
I did a tour and arrived,
these are the people that you're with.
These are basically your family and you have to hide a part of yourself and all
the,
that they were hanging out or doing things that we could become closer.
I was separating myself from that because I knew that there was a part of me
that had to hide.
And so when I bring all of that stuff now too,
to being gay and being open as a conservative and everything,
it is so important for me to be open in that way because there I can't have that
wall there between me and other conservatives and me and other people in the
movement.
And the younger conservatives had been s like,
these kids don't care.
They don't care.
Some of the older ones need to kind of be brought around a little bit,
but man,
they don't care.
Do you think it's just because young people somehow have started to embrace a
more libertarian view of the world?
I mean,
it's like we've got sort of,
you know,
crazy leftism on one hand seems to be catching fire all the time and was really
pushed on us by the media.
But then I see,
and I guess it's a little selected by,
by who invites me to these schools,
but I see such a strong libertarian like spirit with these kids.
Not meaning that they're all politically libertarians at every level,
but like they just,
they want to live their lives.
They want to love who they love,
they want to smoke whatever they want to smoke or whatever.
And,
and I'm very enthused by that.
I think that the,
the generation right now,
they really do just,
they just want to let people live and they want to let people do their thing.
They don't care about gay,
they don't care about transgender,
they don't care about any of these different things.
They just want to let people live.
And it's really funny,
like the conversation I had last night,
I'm at Ucla,
I had an event and it's so funny because when I was protesting against don't
ask,
don't tell,
I was,
you know,
doing a lot of lecture work and I was talking with the young LGBT student groups
and I was just like,
you know,
you can be anything you want to be.
Let's empower you.
Like let's do all this stuff.
And I'm having the same conversations with young people who are afraid to come
out as conservative.
Same thing.
Data.
Yeah,
no,
it is.
All right.
So,
all right,
let's just dive into that then.
So,
because I really do feel this now,
because I find,
I know what the closeted thing was like,
as,
as in terms of sexuality.
But I see this now the amount of emails that I get and when I meet people on the
street and they'll kinda whisper it to me,
you know,
it's not even,
they're not even saying,
yeah,
well they'll go,
you Dave.
And then they'll go,
it's not even that they're saying they're a conservative per se.
They're basically just saying they're not a progressive yeah.
That they're not,
they don't come from the woke monster,
you know what I mean?
And I,
and they're walking around with that,
that feeling that you described a moment ago related to sexuality where you
can't be fully there with someone.
And I think there are,
there are quite literally,
I think there were millions of people in the United States that are walking
around in a,
in a closeted stand,
not because they're Nazis are white,
supremacists are haters are racists,
but just because they happen to have either some conservative beliefs or,
uh,
some libertarian beliefs or something like that.
And I see it all the time and I'm sure you probably get 10 times as many
messages as I do,
but you see it and when you go have these conversations,
it is the same conversations that I was having with a young gay kids that were
afraid to come out.
I had conversation with the kid last night.
He was just like,
man,
how do I come out to my friends as conservative or how do I come out to my
friends as somebody who's like not a leftist and this is what I always say to
them.
You know the real ones will stick around the fake ones.
We'll go,
I promise you that.
And when like a year ago,
I remember sitting,
I was visiting my best friend in Vegas and I was thinking about,
I know from my experience,
you know,
being very prominent in the don't ask,
don't tell thing that when you come out as something like you're coming out to
make a statement and it has to be a media moment and you have to get your face
out there because that's what gives other people the strength to come out.
And I was like,
man,
if I don't do this,
somebody else is going to do this because I know I'm not the only black gay
republican out there.
I have fans that are,
that are Black Gay Republicans and Latina Lesbian Conservatives and all sorts of
stuff.
Um,
but I was like,
if I don't do this,
somebody else is going to do this and somebody needs to do this because these
people need to know that it's okay.
And when I take the hits and you take the hits and canvas takes the hits and all
of these other people takes the hits,
it makes it easier for these other people to come out.
So I've asked a lot of my guests that have taken those heads.
Yeah.
This question,
I usually ask it at the end,
but what do you think it is about you that allows you to,
to want to take the hits or maybe not even want to,
that you do whether you want to or not.
I'm telling you the army built something that is indestructable.
I indestructable I served for five years.
I saw some things on a rock.
I saw some things overseas and in not even outside of that,
what the basic training does is it just builds you up.
And as somebody that has a lot of discipline that can take a lot of hits.
And I know enough about media and I know enough about the people that are making
the moves right now.
I know that it is important for me to do this because,
and I'm telling you,
they have,
and you've probably seen the ship in the past five to seven years since you've
been doing this and have really been blown up and traveling all the,
all the world.
There's a shift that's going on and I believe it's real.
And in three to five years,
me being a black gay conservative,
it's just going to be like,
you know,
whatever.
And I hate the fact that the gay community,
I'm,
I'm Kinda my am ex communicated now,
you know,
so I'm not getting invites to the glazing medium
borough with me.
Yeah,
we should start our own awards.
We totally should.
The,
the,
the gay free thinkers,
wars,
you know,
but you get excommunicated and they're,
they're very high level people that,
I mean,
I used to get invited to,
to all of this stuff in New York City because I was like a person in the media.
And when I came out last year it was like,
it was like silence.
So what does that really tell you about these organizations?
And sorta like glad and these other organizations that are there,
there for gay people,
right?
They're supposed to be for gay people and,
and if they subscribe to,
they should be for
black people in the rest of it.
But you're saying you were in that they loved you.
You come out as conservative.
We're done with you.
Would,
it tells me is number one,
that these organizations are not for all Lgbtq people.
Therefore Lgbtq,
um,
democrats,
first of all,
these are leftist organization.
People really need to understand this.
I know I say it all the time,
but like I think that because people just think glad is for gay people.
This is for this per,
and it's like,
no,
that's not really what's going on here,
but let's go.
Going on really takes work to get people to fully understand why that is true.
And there used to be,
and we talked about this a little bit before we started,
before we started filming,
there used to be a part of me that wanted nothing more than to be kind of like a
gay celebrity.
I like,
oh,
I get to go,
I get to go to the glad media awards and I get to go to the HRC red carpets and
I get to to be,
and now I realize that what I'm doing right now is so much bigger than any of
that stuff.
And I'm not,
I'm doing this not for fame or because the concept of fame has been very strange
to me and in grappling with this newfound attention,
but it's not about being with some delists.
I'm gay celebrities on the red carpet.
It's certainly not about being with,
even though I love the way,
usually the ones that they're putting on the red carpet,
they're not even gay half the time.
Right.
Yeah,
I told you I used to do these red carpets when I had a show on our Q and I was,
so I was interviewing people,
I was on the other side of the red carpet and mostly it was just housewives of
New York drunk,
these drunk plastic women that are like,
ah,
I'll have him gave,
let me tell you something and I can tell you a story and she will remain
nameless.
But I was actually at,
Huh?
It's on me after.
Oh,
I can tell you the name of it.
So yeah.
Yeah.
But I was on one of these award shows and this was obviously before I came out
when I was still getting invited and this person was H's,
a drunken sloppy mess.
And I'm just like,
how is this celebrating gay people?
How is this elevating us?
And so what you have is with the glands of the world,
this is about bullying Hollywood celebrities in the thinking that,
you know what,
if you don't,
if you don't show up to our red carpet events,
you're not supporting,
you know,
the Lgbtq community.
So that's what that's all about.
Um,
the HRC is obviously of leftist organization,
like very much so.
I left this organization and what irritates me about this entire thing is that
these organizations were not started as leftist organizations.
They weren't supposed to be left as well cause at that time they wanted real
equality,
equality under the law.
They wanted the things that we have right now.
But to continue to get funding,
to continue to be data centers for the Democratic Party,
they have to go with whatever far left craziness.
And it's the intersectionality cold and it's,
it's being lectured by a queer Muslim at the glad media where it's about how
gays aren't inclusive enough for,
for Islam and,
and about,
you know,
how,
how the LGBT community needs to accept undocumented people.
It was just like all this stuff that was never,
it's never what our movement was about.
And at the same time for me as a gay man,
I know that um,
HIV aids rates among young black gay men are still exploding.
Um,
we have a huge problem with Matt that there's real stuff still going on.
So what should they have done then?
W W
was there a moment that there should've been a course correction?
So say gay marriage gets passed on,
ask,
don't tell is gone.
What do you think the organization's,
if they had done it right?
I mean,
is it,
do they close up shop?
Do they well,
that's what I think.
That's what they were afraid of.
They were afraid of,
now that we have this quote unquote true quality that the close up shop Chris
Chris rock that had been one of his great lines.
The cops need a certain amount of crime.
Yeah.
And I think that would happen after.
Don't ask,
don't tell.
Repeal and marriage equality were two of the biggest gay rights wins of our
generation.
Like I think of our lifetime.
And after that happened,
I think that they just needed something else.
They needed some more funding.
They needed to,
to continue to be relevant.
So they'd gone into all of this intersectionality far left insanity.
And what I see from being so open and being a gay conservative out here is that
there is a large group of gays and lesbians that are conservative that want
nothing to do with the leftist nonsense.
They don't want to vote with their sexual orientation.
They want to vote for their values.
They want to vote with their pocket books.
And you know,
they,
they want to vote based on who they are.
So you're saying,
let me get this straight.
Yeah.
Gay people are just like everybody else,
just like everybody else.
They just like,
everybody's crazy.
Right?
Nuts.
Insane.
Yeah.
And you'd think
so where are,
where are the,
the right gay organizations?
Are there any,
I mean like the log cabin Republicans,
are there anybody that you're out there and you're like,
oh,
you guys are doing some good grassroots work related to
I issues remain.
It's always,
it's never going to be the HRCS and the glads of the world.
It's always the grassroots organizations.
It's your,
your,
um,
Columbus pride.
You know,
it's,
you're the Brooklyn Community Pride Center.
It's like these are the organizations that are money really needs to go to
because these organizations are doing work on the ground to like give young LGBT
people access to jobs and education and all the stuff that the glads and the HRC
is of the world claim that they're fighting for.
But really they're just paying a lot of big wigs,
sick,
like insane six figure salaries and,
and trying to get Madonna on a re carpet.
And God loved Madonna.
We don't love Madonna,
but that's not the word.
So I always try to elevate the smaller organizations because they need the time
and the money more than the big ones.
For the record,
I'm more of a Tina Turner guy.
You Remember Tina Turner?
I hear she gives an amazing
show.
I haven't been yet.
I never,
well,
I don't think she's going live anymore.
I think she's done tour and she shines.
I think she like,
she moved to like Sweden or something.
I think she gave up her us citizenship and she's just riding it out,
man.